Well, it turns out there's no solution for this equation, let's see why. We know
each of these denominators cannot equal zero, so x cannot equal positive 3 and x
cannot equal negative 3. Remember, we don't want these fractions to be
undefined. This number would make this denominator equal to zero. And this
number would also make this denominator equal zero as well. This last
denominator as factors of x plus 3 and x minus 3. So really we've already have
take in account of numbers that x can not be for it since we solved these two
equations already. If we factor this last denominator we can see that this LCD
would be x minus 3 times x plus 3. We know this since this is a factor of this
denominator. And this is also a factor of this denominator. Next, we multiply
each term by the LCD. We cancel the factors that appear in the numerators and in
the denominators. We're left with 2 times x plus 3 for the first term. And
negative 3 times x minus 3 for the second term. Our last term is just negative
12. Since these factors reduce to 1. This is a linear equation that we're
familiar with. We simply want to distribute this 2 and this negative 3 first and
then combine our like terms and solve for x. Positive 2 x and negative 3 x
equals negative x. And positive 6 and positive 9 equals positive 15. Make sure
you're careful on this distribution. We have negative 3 times negative 3, which
equals positive 9. It's really easy to make that sort of mistake. I'm going to
rewrite this equation up here. Then we subtract 15 from both sides to get
negative x is equal to negative 3. If we multiply through by a negative 1,
positive x would equal positive 3. But we want to be careful here. We know x
equals 3 is an excluded value. It makes this denominator and this denominator
equal to 0. So these fractions would be undefined. Since x equals 3 as an
excluded value up here, we know that there's no solution. There's no real number
that exists that can satisfy this equation.